- What, one thing, well before "Idol"
one thing we have in common
is you waited tables, right.
- Yes.
- So me too.
- Okay. Yeah, I feel like we
have a lot of similarities.
And were you a good
waitress, do you think?
- I was a great waitress.
- Me too.
- I was, yeah.
(audience claps)
I was pretty good, yeah.
- Thank you, I can tell.
- Yeah.
I was working for that tip girl.
- Oh, one hundred percent.
(laughs)
And I know that you like,
you enjoy your wine.
- I really do Amy.
- Yeah.
- I really do.
- Now do you guys --
- I heard that you have like a thing,
a whole thing you used to do with wine.
- Well I'm still kinda proud of the fact
and I mean of course I'm
gonna screw it up now
because I'm doing it on TV,
but I'm kinda proud of the fact
that I can open a bottle of wine
and tell you about the specials
and distract you from the fact
that I'm not doing a great
job opening the wine.
(laughs)
- You're an actor.
- Because you knows
there's a couple of times
when you been opening
wine and then the cork,
like you get half,
and then you're like "just one second,
"I just have to go fetch
something in the kitchen."
and you like "Argh"
like with the knife.
- Luckily you worked at nice places.
I worked at a comedy club
and so mine were like,
it was whiskey.
- Yeah.
- But you know what,
I happen to, I mean it's
weird, interesting, but --
(laughs)
(audience cheers and claps)
I happen to have some fine ACME wine,
I think we've hidden some
stuff to help you out.
- What do we have under here?
- I mean let's celebrate.
- Oh my goodness!
- Let's celebrate.
(audience cheers and claps)
- Amazing.
- Okay.
- Here's your wine glass.
- I say we celebrate smart girls.
- Yes.
- Let's do it.
- I never had to do this as a waitress,
I would have vomited of nerves.
- You never had to do this?
- No, I'm serious, it
was not fancy at all.
They ordered Bud Lite, Amy.
(laughs)
- You never took the Bud Lite
and you ever should it to them like this?
- Would you like a Bud Lite?
- Okay I don't know what we drinking here.
This looks like somebody's good wine.
Okay.
- Okay, let's do it.
- So just a couple of
specials we have today.
(laughs)
- Do you have any pasta?
- We do. We have a delicious gnocchi.
- Is it gluten free?
I'm that person.
- We can make it gluten free.
We can make it gluten free.
Or we can tell you it's gluten free
and you'll never know the difference.
- Exactly.
(audience laughs) until
I'm bloated the next day.
- Yeah.
Let's see.
We have a Branzino tonight that's amazing.
It's served fully, full, not cooked.
(audience laughs)
And you have to cook it yourself.
- It's like a Benny Honna.
- Yeah. You have to go catch it,
but it's so fresh.
- Don't you love fishing?
(giggles)
- We have, what else do we have today?
We have a roasted sirloin.
- With like pasta, like some risotto?
- Yeah, we have risotto.
- Risotto.
- We have risotto ice
cream, which is weird.
- Risotto ice cream?
But I'm into it.
- Weird but good.
- Yeah.
- And then also I'm
trying to help you out.
(audience cheers)
Do you have bread?
- We do have bread.
- Yes.
- You have some bread.
Like a focaccia?
- You know what's so
interesting about bread?
You know what's so interesting.
Look right here.
You know what's so
interesting about bread,
is it really fills you up.
- It does.
- Yeah.
- To where you don't even
have to eat the meal.
You're just like Jesus,
bread and wine.
- So let me guess your birthday.
- Okay.
You must be a Taurus.
(audience cheers)
Okay.
- Okay.
- And now.
- Yes.
- I don't make friends drink alone,
so I'll definitely have this with you.
- This is going to make me go night night.
I can't wait.
- Okay.
- Cheers.
- Is that so wrong though?
- No.
(audience cheers)